earlier today I had a very productive
meeting with Governor Cuomo as you
probably saw to discuss his statewide
testing strategy and how we can work
together to help expand it with the goal
of doubling testing in the next few
weeks and New York State will be
continuing to control the testing of
their citizens and will also manage
their state and local laboratories they
have a lot of great laboratories there
more than anybody would ever have known
frankly the federal government will work
along with the state on the national
manufacturers and distributors together
will all work together to help them
secure additional tests and we hope that
this model will work with the other
states as well I think it will for the
most part New York has a lot of very
exceptional laboratories but most of the
states dudes you saw the chart yesterday
most of the states do I'm proud of the
relationship my administration is forged
with New York and I can say very
honestly with New York State in New York
City they've been terrific to work with
the New York metropolitan area has been
the epicenter of the outbreak here in
America and the federal government has
spared no expense or resource to get New
Yorkers the care they need and the care
they deserve
we've sent over 5 million masks we had
five million masks and now that number
as of about two days from now will be
more than doubled
thousands of ventilators in fact so many
ventilators that the governor is going
to be sending up some to to
Massachusetts and a couple of other
locations we have a great deal of
ventilators which people thought would
be impossible about a month ago
thousands of hospital beds and the USNS
comfort was sent as you know to New York
and it was originally for more of a
normal medical purpose and we changed it
over so that it could take care of
people that had the unfortunate
circumstance
of going through the problem that we
that we know so well unfortunately that
we know so well I said from the
beginning that no American who needs a
ventilator would be denied a ventilator
and we have kept that promise
all over the United States think of that
other countries are desperate for
ventilators they have many deaths
because they don't have a ventilator and
I've asked Andrew if we could bring the
comfort back to its base in Virginia so
that we can have it for other locations
and he said we would be able to do that
Javits Center has been a great help to
them but we'll be bringing the ship back
at the earliest time and we'll get it
ready for its next mission which will
I'm sure would be a very important one
also but it was it was an honor they
they reconverted it after it got they
are into handling an event that they
were not expecting to be handling the
FDA has now authorized more than 50
diagnostic tests including as of late
last night the first taste test that a
patient can take home you can take it at
home and that's highly accurate
LabCorp intends to make the Home
Collection kits available to consumers
in most states with a doctor's order in
the coming weeks we also a for different
antibody tests already authorized tests
will help identify individuals who can
donate convalescent plasma that's
providing potentially life-saving
antibodies to American patients dr. Hahn
we'll be providing you with an update on
these developments and a few moments
he's done a great job at the FDA we
continue to gain ground in the war
against the unseen enemy and I see light
at the end of the tunnel I actually see
a lot of light at the end of the tunnel
and we're starting the process we're
starting a very very powerful important
process you see that people are getting
very anxious they want to get going they
want to get back to their job
they want to make money they want to
take care of their families so the light
is getting brighter and brighter every
day